the 65th conference on the status of
women may have lacked the pomp and
circumstance of years past
not to mention the number of female
participants but it had something
previous conferences did not the first
ever
female vice president of the united
states
it is an honor to address this esteemed
commission
so having a first vp
lady in the u.s you know
it's just amazing the most democratic
country in the whole world
it's amazing it's just such a strong
message for every woman everywhere
promoting women's leadership was the
theme of the year's event
but women like kamala harris germany's
angela merkel
and new zealand's jacinda arden remain
the exceptions on the world stage
around the globe women serve as the head
of state or head of government in just
some
22 countries and even here at the united
nations where women now make up more
than 40 percent of the professional
staff
a female secretary general has yet to be
elected
and covid 19 has been a setback for
women
lockdowns have led to increases in
domestic violence
women leaving the workforce and
disruptions to family planning services
particularly in developing countries the
united nations estimates 12 million
women lost to access to contraception
resulting in 1.4 million unplanned
pregnancies
the status of democracy also depends
fundamentally
on the empowerment of women not only
because
the exclusion of women in decision
making is a marker of a flawed democracy
but because the participation of women
strengthens
democracy and that's true everywhere
the new us administration has promised
to carry the flag for women at the u.n
restoring funding for women's sexual and
reproductive health which was cut by the
trump administration
sexual and reproductive health are so
important
in the in the part of the world where
more maternal mortality is so high
giving this gathering despite recent
setbacks for women
something to celebrate kristen salumi al
jazeera
the united nations